i can't believe it i'm so excited
[Music]
i'm so excited to present an interview
with a woman i have
called my parenting icon but she is
someone that we have come to know
love and respect for a multitude of
reasons
gail king is the real deal and i feel
so lucky to not only speak to her but
soon
we will have sibling shows and with that
i ask her wisdom
guidance and advice about work
love and life drew this is big what
you're doing this is big
this is big so listen i i'm cheering you
on
it's big and it's i think it's
fulfilling i think it's fun
and it's a lot of work it's a lot of
work
but you're up for it you're up for it
i am very tireless and want to put
everything of myself almost into a piggy
bank every day and then
break it on the floor and see what comes
out in that mosaic
yeah i'm going to be your sibling show
so i like that the sibling show
i like that hey drew what are you most
excited about as you're about to start
this
because this is big but this is a lot of
fun
it's a lot of fun what are you most
excited about
um to not play a character
to be myself um
and take everything i've learned along
the way
and make it applicable to the show
i think i've realized that
i'm capable of a lot of change and i
know it wasn't always pretty but
i would get to places so to have that
faith makes me feel like we are all
capable of change
and so i'm excited because you work on
yourself
and you educate yourself until the day
you pass on and then some
and i love humor so i want to try and
put all of that in the piggy bank and i
am a pop culture daily news
obsessed with the world around me you
too
me too i i so love pop culture i so love
politics this is the thing
i am such a news junkie about all things
whether it's politics i said you know i
am just as
interested in talking to mike pompeo
secretary of state
as i am one of the real housewives about
something that happened
or whether there's something that
happened in sports you know when i was a
little kid
they said you know you're so nosy
and nosy i don't take as a compliment i
prefer drew
curious or inquisitive and so i still
sit here
at 65 still feeling uh
curious and inquisitive and you must
have that too where you're just
genuinely interested
about all types of things you talked
about a curation of life
people are interested in what mike
pompeo has to say because it's going to
affect their life
people want to escape into the real
housewives because that's what they need
after dealing with the realities of the
world and sports is the ultimate
thing and the safest thing for people to
argue about at this
juncture you know i i think in the tv
news business i always say i have a
front row seat to life or front row seat
to history
i like to be informed i like to let
people know what's going on but
there's a lot of good out there too and
i don't want us to lose sight of that
it's funny because in late night they're
like you did a great job by
living and getting through the day now
we're going to put you to bed with some
laughs i want to start the day that way
yeah yeah it's true i really
fought to be live because i think are
you going to be live
are you oh drew that's the best
that's the exciting oh i think that's
you know why that's the best
because it happens in real time whatever
happens happens
and even if stuff is going to hell in a
hand basket it's okay
you know when all else fails you can go
to commercial break
but i like that you can be tough if
you're live you can be topical
and there's always something going on in
the news to talk about there's always
something going on in your day-to-day
life
i didn't know you're gonna be live
that's great thought very hard for it
um that show confidence drew barrymore
that you want to be live that's
confidence girl
i'm impressed thank you
the problem is people are still trying
to
look at how oprah did her show and i
think you have to throw everything up
and just start from scratch and come up
with a new
something that's new and different and
going live gives you the opportunity to
do that
because it's it's you can really react
in real time to what's happening
and that alone is is something that will
set you apart
which is really really terrific gail
thinks it's okay
gail thinks it's okay
you know what else is okay when you make
a mistake you just keep going
i think it's silly to act to the
audience that everything is just fine
when really it isn't when really it
isn't and sometimes
it's okay to be imperfect i don't want
i'm not a perfect person
and i don't want to pretend that i am my
daughter's school motto
is brave not perfect yes
if i may like just saying your name
gave me an emotional surge of excitement
um
because you are one of my parenting
icons
oh guarantee icon oh i love you
i love being a mother though drew you
must you must too i loved
i loved every single stage and still do
still do
you wrote something um in your book
that made me burst into tears this
morning
um maybe you would choose to concentrate
on how to manage
life's big relationships imagine being
able to send that word
that marriage gets complicated and that
sometimes the decision to stick it out
or to leave is the best one you will
make in life
i think i think the hardest decision
i've ever had to make in my life and
ever will
was that choice because i too wanted
that perfect family
that four top for life the double date
um and so to have the opposite
experience for my children
than i had and it was as if i made the
ultimate promise
of my life and i wasn't keeping it
um and it was the hardest decision
i've ever made in my life you know back
in the day
people would stay together for the sake
of the children but what messages does
that
send to the children that you should be
miserable and stay in a relationship i
think everybody deserves to be happy
look this is what i realized
as long as kids feel loved and secure
they will be okay
and as long as they know that they have
the both of you and they don't have to
choose sides
that's the thing you you never want them
to feel they have to choose sides or if
they love their dad it's a sight against
you or vice versa
they will really be okay so it took a
minute to get there i'll admit
it took a minute to get there it didn't
didn't happen overnight
you also chose to stay in the same city
yeah and i have such respect for that i
moved from california to new york so
that the girls would be
10 blocks from their dad and not across
the country i get it
i get it listen this is the thing drew
this was way
back when oprah had her show and she was
talking about giving the show up
because she wanted to go into acting she
wanted to go into acting she wanted to
act full-time because she loved acting
so her plan was you move to chicago and
we'll incorporate
you in the show so that at the end of
four years so at the end of the year
then i can sort of pass a baton and i
was
really imagine a huge opportunity i was
really excited about that
and the kids were you know we
were divorced so they were still young
and then i realized that that wouldn't
be fair to them
that that wouldn't be fair to them would
be great for me be really great for me
but that wouldn't be fair to them and so
in the end i decided
to not take her up on that offer but
kirby
favorite daughter kirby favorite son
will their well-being to me was more
important
than whatever career opportunity i i
could have had at the time
and i don't regret that you probably
don't either do you moving
ultimately um i ended up finding
my way tremendous happiness a wonderful
group of friends
um a life that was conducive and the
thing that gave me the most
happiness was though i couldn't control
making a marriage that didn't work work
and the failure and the guilt and the i
mean i've never felt it took me down for
five years i
i couldn't function it was as if i was
letting them down
and but you're not letting them down you
know i had a husband that didn't believe
in monogamy
i happen to think that's important in a
marriage and so
you know you you you're not really
letting them down because you're still
their mother he's still their father and
you're still going to raise them with
an abundance of love so you're not
letting them down
thank you and it is amazing to hear that
from my parenting icon
and the one thing i knew i could control
is that if i put my compass my north
star
in their best interest that no matter
what happened
everything would be okay yes do we all
listen we all grew up
you know with the belief of a nuclear
family or that was my dream that was my
dream of success in nuclear family
and now it's different but it's still
just it still is very fulfilling for
me and i think for them too they would
much rather be
in have us separated and happy than
together
and not you know and and living in a
household that was tense
you know and you think that you're
hiding it too from the kids but they
sense it
it's energy they know everything they
feel it
yes and i fought really hard with his
family
as far as i said there is so much
love and respect and goodness here
that i'm staying nothing is changing
and we're just gonna figure this out one
step at a time
and now i text i'm like okay so when i
come
and the kids are like i'm gonna stay in
the house and
we're gonna do breakfast and everyone's
like great pjs here we go
and there is such functionality and we
put the function in dysfunction
yes are you still close to his family
very close
that's good and do either of you have uh
significant others in your life
um i have not recovered um
i have just i have the kids at their
ages
it's like my cup runneth over i don't
really have the bandwidth
or the interest and i have
i'm so exhausted and it's like kids
work friends um the og
yeah i know i go yeah yeah yeah but i
say it's hard out here for a pimp
in terms of the struggle is real when it
comes to dating
and i always say when you meet the right
one you'll figure out you'll find
your cup runneth over your plate is full
but i'll move the little mashed potatoes
over
and move the spring beans over and i'll
figure it out i will figure it out
well no one's made me want to move my
mashed potatoes
yeah me too me too we do
but i love dating i love romance i am
the ultimate non-cynic
and i am obsessed with love and
relationships because
me too i love love and i love a good
love story
romantic yes me too me too and
i want to be in everyone's dating
business and
life and i'm like yes okay i have a
divorce
but i swear to god i'm good at this you
know why we love love because we still
believe
i do i still believe and listen i don't
ever want to lose that
i don't ever want to lose that can i ask
you
uh a rapid five questions okay okay
um what is your favorite go-to question
what song best describes you i love
that question do you have a dream guest
you know of course everybody wants to
talk to harry and megan
whenever they will talk every year so
there's asking for that always
i still want to talk to felicity huffman
kim jong-un
i'm curious about what he's thinking and
the role that
he's playing you know this is the thing
about the job that we get to do drew
there's always somebody new to talk to i
like being able to introduce the
audience to someone that they've never
heard about
do you have a host journalist uh from
whatever time that is a hero to you you
always remember the person that helped
you
in the beginning for me that's jc
hayward
but what you realize is there's only one
you so try to be the best you you can be
i've never tried to imitate anybody
but just you might take a little bit
from there a little bit from there i
love diane sawyer diane sawyer has a
sophistication that i never felt that i
could pull off but i love
watching diane sorry on tv what is your
research process
did the producers do a really good job
of preparing you
but i like to read the books i like to
see the movies i
because drew i'm always looking for that
one little nugget
and is there a question you wished you
had asked i mean you always have that
when the interview's over
you go i wish i would have asked fill in
the blank
well i think you gave people an
incredible opportunity with this book
because i think we raced through life
being very hard on ourselves
to improve and go forward and we don't
often take the time to look
it's nice to sometimes take a look back
and think about what you've been through
and what you've accomplished
and what you've accomplished wow
i am so excited that i got to speak with
someone
who i could not have any more respect
for
than i already do but i am very excited
to have a sibling show with the great
gayle king
i hope to do her proud she is someone i
have followed
throughout my life and will continue to
do so because she is the example
so thank you gail for taking the time to
continue
to guide me